مجددا وفي الاسود عماره حميداوي عمار اهلا
ومرحبا بك معنا عمار كما تابعنا منذ قليل
في كلمه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن يؤكد
على الدعم الامريكي
اللامحدود
نعم هذا يعني هذه الزياره مهمه جدا
بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا بعد سنه تقريبا من الحرب
الروسيه على هذا البلد الحليف للولايات
المتحده اذا هذه الزياره رمزيه ولكنها
ايضا من الناحيه العمليه مهمه جدا حيث ان
الولايات المتحده تشكل الدعم الاكبر
والرئيسي للقوات الاوكرانيه في هذه الحرب
على مدى اشهر كانت القوات كانت القوات
الاوكرانيه تستند بشكل كبير على نوعيه
السلاح الذي تقدمه الولايات المتحده وهو
سلاح دفاعي اغلبه
على مراحل منذ البدايه بدايه هذا الحرب
وخاصه ان القوات الاوكرانيه كانت تواجه
مصاعب كبيره في التصدي وايقاف تقدم الدروع
الروسيه باتجاه اوكرانيا لكن المساعدات
العسكريه الامريكيه اثبتت نجاعتها وتمكن
القوات كما كانت القوات الروسيه في العديد
من المناسبات يعني استخدام هذه الاسلحه
وتوقيف تقدم القوات الروسيه اذا هذا الدعم
وهذه الزياره هي جاء التتويجا لهذا الدعم
الذي الذي يستمر منذ سنه وايضا ربما
لتطمين الشعب الاوكراني والرئيس زيلينسكي
خاصه بعد تحدث او ظهور تقارير تشير ربما
على ان الدعم الامريكي العسكري لن يكون
بنفس القوه خاصه وان هذه الحرب تكلف
الكثير من الاموال للميزانيه الامريكيه
الرئيس جو بايدن في هذه الكلمه قال بان
هنالك حزمه جديده من المساعدات الامريكيه
تصل الى 500 مليون دولار ستقدم الى الجيش
الاوكراني بعد يومين في كلمه سيقوم
بادلاعها الرئيس بايدن من بولندا وهي
المرحله الثانيه في هذه الزياره حيث سيقوم
بلقاء مجموعه من الجنود الاوكرانيين على
المناطق الحدوديه بين البلدين والذين
شاركوا في هذه المعارك منذ اندلاعها ايضا
رمزيه كبيره ايضا في هذه في هذا الاتجاه
او هذا القرار بالاعلان عن هذه المساعدات
من الميدان اذا ايضا هذه المساعدات لن
تتوقف
بهذه الحد حيث شدد بايدن على ان القوات
الاوكرانيه ستواصل الحصول على الدعم
الامريكي الى ما لا نهايه وهذا المهم
للقوات الاوكرانيه التي تمر بمرحله عصيبه
هذه الايام خاصه بعد يعني
التصدع التي الذي حصلت حصل في جبهه محمود
ويعني قوه الهجوم الروسي في هذه المنطقه
وكذلك الحديث عن اعلان عن امكانيه قيام
القوات الروسيه بهجوم شامل تزامنا مع مرور
سنه لهذه الحرب واستمعنا ايضا لما قاله
الرئيس الاوكراني بمناسبه هذا يقوم بها
رئيس الامريكي الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه
يرى في زياره الرئيس الامريكي علامه دعم
مهمه للغايه كما قال نعم مهمه جدا وهذا
دليل على ان الرئيس اليونسكي لا يزال
يتحصل على دعم واحده من اهم دول العالم من
الناحيه العسكريه والاقتصاديه وهو بذلك
يريد ان يقول ويطمئن الشعب الاوكراني
بانهم لن يكونوا
الوحيدين امام الهجمه الروسيه شاكر
الولايات المتحده وايضا لمح بانه جرى هناك
نقاشات عديده مع رئيس الامريكي خاصه انه
كان قد التقى رئيسا الامريكي وجوجا لوجه
في احد الكنائس القريبه من قصر الرئاسه
ووسط كييف ودار حديث عن شكل المساعدات
الامريكيه وكذلك ربما قدمت تفصيلا
لاحتياجات الجيش الاوكراني في هذه المرحله
ولمح في كلمته بان هنالك مباحثات ايجابيه
كانت مع الرئيس بايدن لكن لم يتطرق الى
مساله مطالبه اوكرانيا بالحصول على طائرات
حربيه امريكيه خاصه وان امريكا كانت قد
رفضت في الوقت السابق وعلما يبدو انها لا
تزال ترفض تسليم القوات الاوكرانيه
لطائرات حربيه امريكيه
وننهي عمار بهذه الكلمه التي قالها الرئيس
الامريكيه الذي عبر عن انبهاره الشخصي
وانبهار الشعب الامريكي بشجاعه الرئيس
الاوكراني
ايضا نعم هذه فيها الكثير من الدلالات
ربما في الدرجه الاولى هي موجهه للرئيس
زلينسكي والشعب الاوكراني لكنها ايضا
موجهه للشعب الامريكي وهي ايضا نوع من
الدفاع عن موقف الولايات المتحده الداعم
لهذا البلد الذي لا زال يقف وحيدا امام
قوات تهدد امن المنطقه وهي روسيا بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده اذا هذه الطريقه في شكر
الرئيس
الاوكراني هي ايضا رساله الى الشعب
الامريكي بان هذا الدعم مبرر ويجب ان نقف
حتى النهايه مع هذا الشعب الذي يقاوم
بشجاعه اكبر الجيوش ربما في المنطقه وهذه
رساله ايضا فيها الكثير من الدبلوماسيه
والتشجيع للولايات المتحده للشعب الولايات
المتحده لمواصله دعم اوكرانيا وكذلك
بالدرجه الاولى لتشجيع الرئيس والشعب
الاوكراني لمواصله الدفاع عن يعني بلدهم
وعدم يعني الاستسلام لهذا الضغط العسكري
الروسي الكبير الذي تتعرض له اوكرانيا منذ
اكثر من سنه شكرا على كل هذه التفاصيل